[THEME MUSIC]
ANDREW BROGDON: All right,
everybody, we're back,
and we have Ian Hickson, tech
lead for the Flutter team.
And we got a bunch of
questions people have asked,
so let's get right to it.
So this one came
in from Twitter,
from M3CT in Islamabad, so
a salaam aleikum, Pakistan.
He wrote, a column with unfixed
hype and a hundred plus list
tiles is a problem.
Do you have any suggestions?
So I'm guessing this is
a performance situation.
If you just put a bunch of
list tiles in a column, and--
that's a lot of work that
Flutter's doing at that point.
IAN HICKSON: Yeah, you
really, really want
to only be building
the widgets that
are actually on the screen.
That way, we don't
waste any CPU cycles
building things, laying
them out, painting them,
if they're not on the screen.
So the easiest way to do
that-- listview.builder.
You literally just tell it
how many items you have,
and it will just call
you for each item.
And you build that
item, and then
we won't even call you
again unless it changes
until the thing
goes off the screen
and then comes back
on the screen later,
we'll call you again.
ANDREW BROGDON: And
so with that, it's
not recycling anything
the way that a lot
of-- like Recycler View
on Android, and there's
a similar control on iOS.
It's not recycling
any widgets there.
It's rebuilding when necessary.
IAN HICKSON: That's right.
We don't actually need to
keep any of the objects
around because Dart's
garbage collection basically
makes that very efficient.
We just allocate the
objects we need on the frame
when we need them,
and then we use them.
And then when they go off
screen, we get rid of them.
ANDREW BROGDON: Cool.
All right, so hopefully,
that helps out.
Oh, here's an interesting one.
This one comes from Sudan,
so salaam aleikum again.
This is from
[INAUDIBLE],, I think.
Hopefully, I got a good
pronunciation of that.
Can we build games with Flutter,
and how would the performance
be?
IAN HICKSON: Ah, depends
on the kind of game.
You can't really build a 3D game
with Flutter, like "Quake" or--
ANDREW BROGDON: So Flutter
doesn't expose 3D sort of--
IAN HICKSON: Right.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Things like that.
Right?
IAN HICKSON: You
can do 2D games.
In fact, one of our earliest
demos was a 2D game.
You may have seen it
in some of the screen--
some of the videos
during the keynote today.
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh,
the sliding title game?
IAN HICKSON: That's right.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
IAN HICKSON: And
also another one--
much earlier one
that we had was the--
another space shooter game.
That was also--
ANDREW BROGDON: I think I've
also seen that in the keynote
as well.
IAN HICKSON: Right.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
IAN HICKSON: We don't
support that really,
as a first class citizen.
We don't have a
framework built for that.
But there are frameworks
in the community,
the community's provided,
to do exactly that.
I think Flutter Sprites,
I think it's called.
It's one of them.
ANDREW BROGDON: I've
seen that package, yeah.
IAN HICKSON: And the
performance is fine.
I mean, we're designed to
render pixels on the screen,
and games do that
just like UIs do that.
There's not really a difference
from the engine's perspective.
ANDREW BROGDON: I've heard that,
that the actual under the hood
architecture, a
built-for-release Flutter
app actually isn't
that different
than a typical mobile game.
Is that--
IAN HICKSON: Yeah,
it's actually very
similar to-- the
way Flutter apps
work is very similar,
in many ways,
to how a Unity game would work.
We literally just
drive all the pixels,
and we update the parts of the
2D scene, which under the hood,
is a 3D scene in the GPU.
We update that when
it changes, and we
leave the stuff that hasn't
changed when [INAUDIBLE]..
ANDREW BROGDON: Interesting.
In Unity, everything built
on top of the renderer
is going toward the use case of
games and optimized for that,
and Flutter is going
mostly toward apps
and those sorts of use cases.
That's really interesting.
All right, let me see
what else we have.
Here's a good one.
This is from
[INAUDIBLE] in Brazil,
and it's a question
about, when would you
build a Flutter app versus
a mobile friendly website?
So what is actually harder
with HTML, CSS, and JavaScript
that would be easier in Flutter?
Why would you prefer
one to the other?
IAN HICKSON: So I mean
that really depends
on who your target audience is.
And honestly, if you're a big
company writing a big app,
you might want to do both.
You might want to
have your mobile web
app for those people who
haven't downloaded your app.
ANDREW BROGDON: That's true.
IAN HICKSON: Or who
are on a device like--
[INAUDIBLE] device or a laptop
or something-- whatever.
And then you might also
want your mobile app
for people who want the
more native experience.
With Butterfly--
sorry, not Butterfly.
With Hummingbird, we are maybe
going to make that easier.
We'll see how that goes.
ANDREW BROGDON: Awesome.
Yeah, I'm looking forward to
seeing where that project goes.
WM LELER: I've got a couple--
I've got a couple of
questions that came in.
ANDREW BROGDON: Fire away, yeah.
WM LELER: So we have a
couple of live questions.
The first one is, in
the future, are we
going to have support for
Android or Apple Watch?
IAN HICKSON: I have no idea.
[LAUGHS]
WM LELER: But we could, right?
IAN HICKSON: We could.
I mean, there's no reason
why we couldn't do that.
We're really targeting
mobile right now.
We're starting to
look at desktop.
WM LELER: Watches are mobile.
IAN HICKSON: Well, it's true.
One thing we have done, we
have a demo, very early demo
we did, to prove that we are not
fixed to Cartesian coordinates.
We have a sector demo,
which renders UI using--
literally using
polar coordinates,
which if you have a round
clock face, would be perfect.
WM LELER: An analog
watch-- that's
all on polar coordinates.
ANDREW BROGDON: So no boxes.
Just sectors of a circle and
truncated them as they go.
WM LELER: Ah, wow.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
WM LELER: So what
we're saying is
we don't know if
we're going to--
we're probably not going
to do something like that,
but we would love it
if somebody else tried
to do something like that.
IAN HICKSON: I certainly would
love contributions to do that.
We don't have anything on our
roadmap right now for a watch.
WM LELER: But it certainly
is something that
there's-- there's a reason why
it might actually be a good
thing to do in Flutter if
you can do polar coordinates,
so that sounds great.
ANDREW BROGDON: And so you have
one more, and I have one more.
And then I think we're
going to let you go.
IAN HICKSON: All right.
ANDREW BROGDON: What's
your other question?
WM LELER: My other
question is, we all
know that Flutter
came from Chrome,
and the question was, how
has the original team used
their previous knowledge
from Chrome to build Flutter?
And which features
were inherited
from Chrome to Flutter, if any?
IAN HICKSON: Well, from
the code perspective,
we literally started from Blink.
We forked Blink and
then basically started
deleting code.
And I think, at this point,
there's no code left.
We literally have no code left.
We still use the same
graphics engine, Skia.
I think there's literally
nothing else left.
We don't use the same
scripting engine.
text layout anymore.
WM LELER: But it's
fair to say that there
was some experience
you had with Chrome
that sort of informed how
you went about building this.
IAN HICKSON: Absolutely.
If you look at our
internal style guide--
it's on our wiki somewhere.
There's a document
that talks about how
you should design, our
design philosophy, and so on.
If you look at some of
our earliest bullet points
on there, it specifically
talks about how
to avoid some of the mistakes
we had made on the web
before using--
mentioning document.write,
for example.
Avoid document.write style APIs.
So yeah, we're very
much learning from that.
We've also hired
plenty of people from--
people who've worked on the
Android team and people who've
worked on other
platforms, and we're
using everyone's knowledge.
We're really trying to learn
from all of our experiences.
WM LELER: Great.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah,
so we have one more,
and then we're going to let you
get back to enjoying the party.
What feedback does
the engineering
team most value coming from
the developer community?
Because as we asked
Eric, what can
developers who want to
get involved do to make--
have a chance at some
really going to impact.
Developers that
are using Flutter--
what are some of the
things you need from them?
IAN HICKSON: All
feedback is great.
We really love all feedback.
ANDREW BROGDON: Done.
IAN HICKSON: Even
positive feedback.
I don't mind if you file a
bug that says, "You're great."
But when you do file a bug,
the most useful thing for us
is make sure there's
reproducible test cases.
Make sure you have
a piece of code
that we can just
download and run
that shows the bug
really clearly.
That's really useful for us.
If we just have a vague
comment-- like, hey, sometimes
my app crashes.
I don't know what your app does.
I don't know what
device it crashes on.
I don't know what's going on.
But if you tell me, hey, when I
run this specific function on--
I don't know-- a Samsung
G5 or whatever, crashes,
then that's much more helpful.
I can go get that phone.
I can go run that app, and
I can test it and reproduce
the problem and try to fix it.
WM LELER: You have to be able
to reproduce it, in other words?
IAN HICKSON: It is very helpful.
I should say, if you
can't reproduce it,
it's still worth filing the
bug because if 10 people file
10 vague bugs that all say,
hey, when I do this, it crashes,
we might notice a pattern.
For example, there's one bug
that we're still dealing with.
We haven't figured out
exactly what's going on.
We figured out it only happens
with Windows 10 in China.
I think it's when you're
doing a hot reload, something
like that.
But we were only able
to figure that out
because we looked at
a whole bunch of bugs
that were filed at different
times, and 90% of them
mentioned Windows,
and 90% of mentioned,
oh, it's a problem with China--
or it mentioned that
they were in China.
And then we noticed,
we don't have
any of this bug outside China.
So file the bug.
That's the most important thing.
And then once you file
the bug, if you can,
provide reproducible steps.
ANDREW BROGDON: That's great.
Thank you so much for--
IAN HICKSON: You're welcome.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Thanks for coming.
I hope everybody out
there enjoyed it.
You can go-- head
straight out that way
and take the
microphone with you.
We're going to answer
some more questions.
IAN HICKSON: Goodbye, folks.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right.
WM LELER: Thanks, again.
ANDREW BROGDON: Ian
Hickson, everybody.
WM LELER: That was great.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right,
let's do livestream.
WM LELER: Yeah, let's
look at the livestream.
We haven't done very much
livestream recently, so let's--
ANDREW BROGDON: We're getting
livestream from Twitter.
Let's go-- let's get back
into the YouTube livestream
and see what I have here.
WM LELER: Well, if you're
looking for a second,
I've got a question that
I can answer really fast.
ANDREW BROGDON: Go for it.
WM LELER: So we
just had somebody
who wrote in just
a few minutes ago.
They said, is there any chance
of having Kotlin on Flutter?
And I have a stock
answer for that one,
which is, if you're willing
to give up hot reload, sure.
But so far, nobody's
taken me up on that.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah, so hot--
stateful hot reload
is one of the features
that Flutter can
get with Dart that's
not easy to find in
a lot of languages.
Hot loading code with
Kotlin into a running JVM.
Dart is built for
that kind of thing,
with its just-in-time compiler
and all of the other stuff.
They can still compile the
native code at the end.
And so there is still Kotlin
code in a Flutter app.
If you want to, you could
build platform channels code
with Kotlin, for example.
You're not tied to
Java necessarily there.
But the particular features
that Flutter needs,
it really gets from Dart.
WM LELER: There's actually
an article that I wrote--
self plug right here--
called "Why Flutter Uses Dart."
And if you're curious about
what are the advantages of Dart,
you can read that.
It's on the web.
Just search for what--
"Why Flutter Uses
Dart," and that'll help
answer that question.
Have you found anything?
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah,
we've had a couple here.
WM LELER: Go for it.
ANDREW BROGDON: We
have one from Pedro
who posted, is Flutter IO
going to replace Android?
WM LELER: Is Flutter what?
ANDREW BROGDON: Is Flutter
going to replace Android?
Will Android development be--
WM LELER: So this is
just like the question
we answered earlier, when
people were asking us
about React native
and stuff like that.
No, Flutter is not going
to replace Android.
That's like asking--
ANDREW BROGDON: They're
two very different things.
Android's an operating
system, and Flutter
is a software development kit--
WM LELER: They're
not even related.
ANDREW BROGDON: --to help
people build apps, right?
WM LELER: Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah, so
they're two different masters,
and they're--
WM LELER: And even if you're
wondering if straight ahead
Android development
is going to replay--
be replaced by
Flutter, none of us
think that's going
to happen either.
I mean, it's not like
something new comes along,
and it gets rid
of something else.
There are things that
Android does really well
and that it would be hard to do
in a cross platform type tool.
So there's definitely use
cases that will always
be valuable for that.
I mean, we can name
examples of that,
but I think they've
gotten the idea.
Let's go on to the next one.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah, I just
skipped past a question asking
about background
tasks and Flutter
and some things like that, which
we can touch on a little bit.
So certainly,
again, a Flutter app
built for Android is
still an Android app,
and a Flutter app
built for iOS is still
just a typical iOS app.
And you can add code to do
a number of things that way
on the platform side.
We use platform channels
to talk back and forth.
But speaking of
background tasks,
I was talking with
Ben the other day.
Have you seen Ben's
background task article
that he wrote about geofencing
and scheduled tasks?
If you haven't seen
it, it's great.
He wrote a very detailed
example and had source code up
on GitHub for how to
make a Flutter app
that used geofencing to do
certain things in response
to GPS events.
And so he had--
WM LELER: That's definitely
a need for background tasks.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Exactly, and he had
an app that was opening
his garage door when he
arrived home with his bicycle.
And so the source for that
is actually on GitHub.
If you do a search for it,
background-- geofencing
and Flutter, you'll find did.
He did great job in the
article and put all the code up
where people can see it.
So that might well
answer your question
and show you how to
get started with that.
WM LELER: I've got
another question here.
It's from somebody.
They're asking
what are the tools
and what are the
processes I could
use to optimize my Flutter app?
And they're talking about--
they were working on an app,
and it took up more
space than they wanted.
And the performance was
not where they want it.
ANDREW BROGDON:
I just saw Devon.
This is perfect.
WM LELER: You saw-- yeah,
exactly, I saw Devon, too.
So we actually
have the guy who's
in charge of Flutter tooling.
Devon, would you come on up?
ANDREW BROGDON: We're going
to spend a little time
on my laptop here.
Let me get back to you--
back into it.
This is just my scratchpad app.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Devon Carew
from the tooling team
and our Portland office.
Real quick, what are all the
responsibilities that you have?
What are some of the things
that you cover in your work?
DEVON CAREW: We do cover a bunch
of things on the tooling team.
We make plugins for the
major IDEs we support.
IntelliJ and Android Studio
both, and Visual Studio Code
as well.
We work on static
analysis tooling,
so that is a command line
tool and a language server.
Command line tools that Dart
analyzed with language server
is actually interesting.
It's a separate process
which powers support and IDEs
through a protocol,
so it's how we're
able to provide support
for multiple IDEs
in an economic way.
We support some other tools
like DartDoc and DartPad
and the language playground.
ANDREW BROGDON: Of course,
I use DartPad all the time.
So a lot of the
things that we think
of as making developers'
lives easier,
you are the one overseeing
production of those?
DEVON CAREW: Yes,
for much of it, yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: So
I use IntelliJ IDEA.
I use that.
That's what I like to use.
If I had, say, this--
let me get an app going here.
Say it was misbehaving,
and I didn't know why.
It was dropping frames
or something like that,
or chewing up gigabytes
of RAM on my phone
and heating it up so I
could fry an egg on it.
What are some of
the tools that I
can start looking into to
get a handle on that problem?
DEVON CAREW: Yeah,
so that's an area
that we've been working on
more in the past quarter 2
and going forward as
well, performance tooling.
We want to make it so that--
when Flutter was
very small, users,
if they had
performance problems,
they could come to
the Flutter team,
and we could help solve
their performance problems.
ANDREW BROGDON: It doesn't
quite scale that way.
DEVON CAREW: As
Flutter gets bigger,
we want to make it so they
can solve the problems
themselves through either good
documentation or good tooling.
And if you go to
the Flutter website,
we already have
some docs about ways
you can make your
apps more performant,
best practices, Flutter.IO.
ANDREW BROGDON: So just
performance maybe off that?
DEVON CAREW: I-- yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: There we are.
DEVON CAREW: And we're
also in parallel,
building out new tooling as
well to help you with that.
And we're concentrating
mostly on UI jank tooling--
so, "my app is missing frames."
Basically to help people be
better aware when they're
missing frames, and then
why-- if they missed a frame,
why are they doing that.
And then the other side is
we're looking at memory tooling
as well to give people a better
sense of their memory usage,
and if they're using a
lot, where's it going?
Is it a leak, or is it
just a lot of resources?
So some of that
tooling is shipped now
and available in IntelliJ
and Android Studio,
and some will be coming
out in a few quarters.
ANDREW BROGDON: In
the pipeline and I
think I have the latest version
of the plugin right here
and the latest
version of IntelliJ.
I just updated.
So--
DEVON CAREW: Yeah,
so if you have--
ANDREW BROGDON: There are
some things on the sides here
that I can see, and what--
where am I going first, do
you think, to find some jank?
DEVON CAREW: For
performance, you
want to go to our
Flutter Performance tab.
It's on the bottom.
It's active.
Whenever an app is running,
you'll have this available.
There's some simple
options we have,
which are useful, that are just
enabling features, performance
features already in
the Flutter framework,
so if you toggle on the
performance overlay--
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh,
I got some stuff.
DEVON CAREW: And then you
interact with your app,
you can see your frame rate.
We have the same
information available Inline
and IntelliJ as well.
And if you toggle
that off, there's
another one, which is useful.
It's the debug drawing toggle.
It's, I think, the
second-- yeah, third one.
It just sort of shows you
the outline of your widgets
and gives you a
sense of-- that's
more for debugging layout.
ANDREW BROGDON: So if I have
something that's not where it
needs to be, I can quickly come
in here with this and just--
it's like putting Border
equals 1 on something--
DEVON CAREW: It's a good way of
just getting an overall sense
of your layout.
We also have Flutter Inspector
for a very detailed knowledge,
but a performance
feature we just
launched-- if you want
to toggle off Debug Draw
and check this Show
Widget Rebuild Information
and give your code.
So what we've done is we've
instrumented your code
at runtime to display
inline in the editor, which
widgets are rebuilding.
It's really magical if you've
been doing Flutter for a while
and haven't had this feature.
So as you interact,
we'll show you
which widgets are rebuilding.
If widgets are rebuilding much
more than you-- sometimes,
having them rebuild
is perfectly natural.
But sometimes, you can end
up rebuilding much more
than you expect, and that could
indicate a performance issue.
It doesn't mean it is, but--
ANDREW BROGDON: And so
that was just that little--
on line 32, I think it
was, I saw that text
widget as it was building.
DEVON CAREW: Yeah,
but we have the--
If you give that a bit
more space on the bottom,
you can see a table
of widget rebuilds.
This app is not
doing a whole lot.
If your app was
more sophisticated,
you'd see the widgets that were
rebuilt, how many times they
were rebuilt, and if you
double-click on that widget,
it'll take you to where in
the source it was created.
So then you need to give
your source of that one.
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh, yeah,
it helps if you actually
show the source window.
DEVON CAREW: Yeah, so--
ANDREW BROGDON: And there it is.
[INAUDIBLE]
DEVON CAREW: This
is all just launched
in last month's release
and this month's release,
and we actively use
a lot of user studies
to tweak this,
and user feedback.
So this last release, I
think the changes we made
were just driven by
user studies of trying
to validate that the
tooling we'd shipped
was actually solving the
performance problems users were
having.
ANDREW BROGDON: I mean,
the rebuild indication
of the widgets is great not only
for performance information,
but also as people are
probably learning Flutter.
DEVON CAREW: Well.
It gives you a better insight
to what your app is doing.
Not performance
related, but just--
so yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: So one of the
other questions-- we got this,
I think, a little bit earlier--
was relating to Observatory,
which I know is, at the moment,
a bit of an advanced tool.
But can we take a look
at that, and maybe
you show me some of the
things that are going on
with Observatory as well?
DEVON CAREW: Well, I think one
of the main features you should
use observatory for,
in a Flutter context,
is their timeline
view, which gives you
a very detailed view of the
events that your app is going
through, and in
particular, it can
help you identify slow frames
and why those frames are slow.
This is some of the tooling
we're actually rebuilding
to make it more user
friendly, but right now
is the only way, really, to
debug UI jank in your app.
But it's one of
the ones that we do
want to make basically
more approachable
to your typical user.
So if you go into
this View Timeline
and then check all these boxes--
you're going to check those.
Go back to your application.
Interact with it a little bit.
Click a button or two,
and then if you go back
to the timeline view
and choose Refresh.
So in a new version
of this app, you
wouldn't have to toggle
those options on or refresh.
It would just be
streaming data live.
But you can now see,
in the timeline view--
and we don't need to get into
much more detail than this,
I think.
But you can see events for
when frames were created,
when your build
method was running,
what was happening
in that build method,
and basically, in an
iteration of this,
we hope to make it much
more actual for users.
Once they see this
data, what does it
mean they should do to their
app to make it more performant?
Or is there a performance
problem at all,
or would they just
be optimizing where
it's not really necessary?
ANDREW BROGDON:
And so I got here
through a link in IntelliJ.
This is a web server that's
just running on my machine.
DEVON CAREW: Exactly, yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: But I'm
afraid we've hit our time.
We do need to say goodbye to you
and answer some more questions
here before we end our Q&A.
WM LELER: We've got a couple
of coming in, so that's good.
Thanks for coming out.
DEVON CAREW: Absolutely.
Np problem.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Thank you so much.
That was really great.
DEVON CAREW: All right.
ANDREW BROGDON: Awesome.
Devon Carew, everybody.
WM LELER: So I got a
couple of questions.
First one should be
a pretty easy one.
The question is-- well, I
like the way they said it.
They said, it's time
to end the debate.
Which is better-- VSCode
or IntelliJ/Android Studio?
ANDREW BROGDON: Well, I mean,
I think we just saw there,
all of those are supported
for Flutter development
by Devon and his team.
There's a bunch of
engineers working on them.
I think they're all going
to end up coexisting.
Everybody likes their--
WM LELER: Yeah.
I mean, I think, during the
keynote, most of the demos
were on the VSCode.
A lot of people internal
in Flutter use VSCode.
ANDREW BROGDON: And
there's a lot of people--
Phillip, I think, likes
Android Studio normally.
I use IntelliJ.
There are people,
engineers on the team that
use the text editor,
that use VI or Emacs or--
WM LELER: Yeah, you
have to mention Emacs
or you'll be in trouble.
ANDREW BROGDON: You
got to use both.
WM LELER: Exactly.
But I think one of the
differences is, I think,
some of the new features do
appear on IntelliJ first,
but they get to
VSCode very quickly.
So I think this is going to be
just like every other question
people ask us about this.
It's like-- which
one's the best?
The best is the one
that you already know
how to use, and just use it.
I happen to use
IntelliJ just because I
have to end up testing a lot of
the new features that come out.
I actually work with Devon and
the rest of the tooling team,
so they throw a
lot of things at me
because I'm a good
idiot for idiot testing.
But it really depends on
what's important to you,
but it really is up
to you what you use.
There's not really a huge
difference between them.
So I've got one more
that I have to ask.
ANDREW BROGDON: All
right, go for it.
WM LELER: Because we're
running out of time.
The question is-- and
it's a great question
because it answers itself.
The question is, how do
you pronounce Fuchsia?
ANDREW BROGDON: [LAUGHS]
A question about Fuchsia
I actually know how to answer.
You've already answered it.
WM LELER: That's one of the
few questions about Fuchsia
that we can actually answer.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Yes, that's right.
WM LELER: If you don't know what
Fuchsia is, it's open source.
You can go look at it.
That's about all we
should say about it.
ANDREW BROGDON: That's
about all I know about it.
One of the reasons I like
working on an open source
project is that I'm not
good at keeping secrets,
so I just don't learn
them in the first place.
Everything with
Flutter is in the open,
so it's very easy to talk about.
Don't ever have
to worry about it.
WM LELER: Do you have anything
coming from the livestream?
ANDREW BROGDON: Let me
double check real quick.
WM LELER: Because we're
kind of running out of time.
ANDREW BROGDON: I
know, we're going
to have to let everybody
go in a minute.
Let's see.
WM LELER: Anything interesting?
ANDREW BROGDON: There's a
question about accessibility
that just came up.
Of course, accessibility
is a big concern.
When I joined the team, one of
my first meetings on the team
was an accessibility--
not a review, but the person
who does accessibility reviews
came in and talked to us
about the tools that we have
and how to use-- how
to take advantage
of the native ones
in Android and iOS.
There is an accessibility that
Symantec Tree and Flutter--
if you ever see that
referenced, that is,
in part, for accessibility.
It's a feature that's
been designed into Flutter
from very early on.
What else do we have here?
Someone noted that they're
installing Flutter right now.
WM LELER: Yeah!
ANDREW BROGDON: Well done.
Good on you.
WM LELER: You're obviously
not here at the party, though.
ANDREW BROGDON: Somebody was
wondering about Positioned,
which was a widget I--
WM LELER: What?
ANDREW BROGDON: Positioned,
which was a widget
that I used earlier.
Positioned is a widget used with
stacks, sort of like Expanded
is used with a row.
So with a stack,
you are stacking up
children one on top of each
other, and you use Positioned,
maybe you want to have a
small one on top of a big one,
and you want it in the
lower left-hand corner.
Or you want to make
sure it completely
stretches to fill the entire
height and width of the stack.
That's what Positioned is
for, and it's meant-- usually,
it's the first order
child of a stack.
WM LELER: Awesome.
ANDREW BROGDON: Some people
calling out issue numbers.
So they're looking at the--
WM LELER: App?
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
Somebody's asking about
the impact of Flutter
on the app size.
That is something that
matters a lot, certainly
in certain parts of the world.
Right now on Android, another
number is just over 4 megs
to get you just the engine
and the basic widgets.
That number was
much higher when--
just when I joined the team.
I think it was like 6
or 8 or something like.
WM LELER: It was
6.7 for a while,
and they actually had
not done any work trying
to get that down.
And finally,
somebody said, well,
let me play with it a little
bit, and it dropped down to 4.
ANDREW BROGDON: They're
like, this is it.
Now it's time to
do the shrinking.
WM LELER: And they're not even
willing to say that it would be
that hard to do it even better.
They got rid of that much
just by eliminating things
that were naturally being
generated by the build process,
but weren't being used.
He just figured that
out and stopped those
from being emitted.
So there's almost
certainly more things
that they can do to
get the space down,
and I know that's something
they're still working on.
ANDREW BROGDON: I think
it's actually part
of the CI process for the SDK.
I think they build an app just
to see if they've bloated it
at all, and look at that
as one of the metrics
every time they make a change.
So it's definitely on the
team's mind and something
that's very important.
I think we're going to be
running out of time here quite
soon.
Maybe we have time for one more.
Do you have one more from
Twitter maybe we can cover?
WM LELER: Sure.
Can you talk about artificial
intelligence and machine
learning integration on Flutter?
ANDREW BROGDON: Sure.
Well, you had a great
demonstration, obviously,
with what you saw
in the keynote.
Maurice is working
on some great things.
We're hoping to have
a devrel sample for ML
in Flutter in the
coming quarter,
in part because we just
really want to build it.
I mean, who doesn't want to
build something like that?
And so that's there.
For more advanced
ML cases, where
you might want more direct
access to TFLite or something
like that, platform channels is
a way that you can go as well.
So like I said--
we've been saying
for a while now.
With Flutter, you
have a great degree
of freedom for things
with platform channels.
And so if you ever see a plugin
that's not quite your use case,
or you don't see a plugin for
a tool that you want to use,
you can always go
use it yourself.
You can always build that
bridge yourself and get access
to it that way.
And when you do, please
post it on GitHub.
Make a package out of it so the
next person can use it as well.
WM LELER: That's right.
ANDREW BROGDON: All
right, I think we--
WM LELER: I've got one more.
What about Code Push?
Is there going to
be a Code Push, sort
of like Microsoft Code Push?
ANDREW BROGDON: Code Push?
Sure.
WM LELER: Might want to define
it because not everybody knows
what Code Push is.
ANDREW BROGDON: Code Push
is a very popular piece
of technology that Microsoft,
I believe, has made and--
open sourced I think--
to push live code to an
app that has been released.
I think, with React
Native for example,
because they're
using a JS VM, you
can push new JS code
to the VM using this.
And so this is something--
the way Dart works in debug,
is you have a VM, and you
have just-in-time compilation.
But when you build
for release, you
are compiling a
native [INAUDIBLE]
binary to a static
[INAUDIBLE],, and so you are not
using a just-in-time
compiler at that point.
And so it's not something
that's supported yet,
but I've heard this--
like, hallway conversations
about this.
So it's the kind of thing--
I don't know if it has a
definite place on the roadmap,
but it's definitely
in people's heads.
And I think we'll
end up there soon.
WM LELER: I know that
people are looking at it.
I just don't know if
it's on the schedule yet.
I have to say, I
see that they're
going to take a group photo
of everybody who's here,
so I think this is a great time
for us to say goodbye and get
in the group photo.
ANDREW BROGDON: So yeah.
So obviously, we weren't
able to get all--
we had a lot of great
questions today.
We weren't able to
get to all of them.
So if we didn't get
to your question,
we will try to get to
them all after the fact
and go in and answer on Twitter.
If we saw one on YouTube,
we'll try and get it
on the "Boring Show."
If you've ever seen that,
it's sort of our video podcast
where we answer questions
and hack on things.
We also want to leave you
with a bunch of resources
that we have to grow
as a Flutter developer.
Some of them-- there's a
ton made by the community,
and we on the Flutter team have
some that we can offer you.
We have the Flutter
Samples repo.
We have the Docs.
CROWD: Woo!
ANDREW BROGDON: We have
the Docs, the Code Labs,
the Flutter Cookbook,
and Flutter.IO.
WM LELER: I think they--
ANDREW BROGDON:
They're clapping for us
WM LELER: [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW BROGDON: You
can come join us
on Gitter on our Flutter
slash Flutter channel,
on Twitter @FLUTTER.IO.
We also have a big
playlist of YouTube videos
we've made, like the "Boring
Show" and "Widget of the Week."
And speaking of YouTube, I
need to thank the small army
of people behind the
scenes tonight who have
helped us put this together.
Let me just name some of them.
We have John and Adam as
tech lead and tech support.
We've got Simon to
the back on audio.
Neil is the project manager.
Derek, Daniel, Luke, and
Rick are on graphics.
The social team are
Robert, Justin, and David.
Crystal, Gabe, and
Phil are producing.
Ash is directing.
He is Wm Leler.
I am Andrew Brogdon.
Good night from Flutter
Live and happy coding.
WM LELER: We have
had a great time.
Thank you, all.
[THEME MUSIC]